there was a planet it was one of the few
planets in its entire galaxy cluster
that contained life and one of the even
fewer that made it all the way to the
first form of conscious life a species
that descended from a long lineage of
inconceivably good fortune comprised of
the right traits in the right planetary
conditions at the right time like a
newborn baby opening its eyes for the
first time the emergence of this species
was opening the eyes of the universe out
from the crust of the planet they were
the first organism on the planet to
recognize that they were an organism on
a planet not only able to be and feel
and sense the material of everything but
able to think and wonder and create out
of it all able to harness the elements
of the planet into tools and
technologies able to transmute the
chemicals of their own biology and
demeaning and love and fellowship they
were a product of infinity an anomaly of
existence although rich with
intelligence and self-awareness although
capable of great acts of creation and
understanding their bodies and organs
remain soft vulnerable and short lived
during the better part of the species
initial development individuals lived on
average for only 40 years not much
longer than anything else on the planet
in fact shorter than many things at
which point their bodies decayed enough
to shut down turning off the spotlight
of their individual consciousness
forever not only that but many died
early their bodies being a complex
fragile and predominantly liquid based
system meant that any number of
incidents of damage could shut the whole
thing down furthermore in many cases
even if the body went on harm from the
outside it still remains susceptible to
various diseases that developed
internally viruses microorganisms and
other materials could take form
destroying their bodies from the inside
the same consciousness that granted the
species their incredible abilities of
understanding and art and science and
technology and love and meaning was the
same consciousness that made them aware
of the fact that they were a
consciousness stuck inside an absurd
fragile short-lived body destined to
lose it all when my perhaps think that
the awareness of their mortality would
have compelled them to live as if they
were going to die but for the most part
it had the opposite effect the knowledge
that they were going to die and the
expectation of how much time they likely
had before they did created a horrible
friction between how much to focus on
the present versus
how much on the future which in many
cases defaulted into an inertia and many
lived as if they would live forever
rarely appreciating or making the most
out of their magnificent position there
was however a phenomenon that seemed to
change things and a portion of
individuals sometimes a disease or
condition would develop one that could
be diagnosed but not sufficiently
treated or cured and as a result the
individuals life expectancy would reduce
some of these diseases were slow burning
and left the individual with several
mostly untainted years left before it
did them in the diseased individual
would then be forced to live not only
with the awareness that they were going
to die but the awareness that they were
going to die sooner than they expected
most commonly this would occur in their
mid life and typically reduce the
individuals life expectancy from 40 down
to around 20 or 15 years whenever this
happened for some reason they would
often make major changes in their life
as if they weren't already living in a
way that was suitable for their
mortality suddenly they seemed to say
more of what they wanted to say do more
of what they wanted to do be more of who
they wanted to be every moment became
immensely more valuable to them they
often slowed down and more frequently
appreciated the nature of everything
around and in them squeezing all the
life out of the life they had left even
though they were already going to die
when their expectations of when was cut
down the true shortness of their life
suddenly revealed itself five hundred
years would go by as a result of
technology and medical advancements the
species managed to increase the average
life expectancy of their bodies to 75
years the result of a long laborious
effort to add more time to their
existence however their frame of
reference and expectation of life's
length simultaneously increased
alongside 35 more years were added but
life felt no longer nor shorter to them
although there were fewer during this
time there still remained plenty of
diseases that exceeded the species
medical understanding diseases that
could be diagnosed but not sufficiently
treated or cured and was shortened the
deceased individuals lifespan now
however when individuals were diagnosed
with these certain diseases and most
commonly reduced their lifespans down to
their 30s or 40s after the diseased
individual received the news
still had time and were not yet
incapacitated they often began living
and thinking and acting differently
making major changes in their life even
though the length of their now shortened
life was just as long if not longer than
their ancestors full lives the exact
same phenomenon occurred 400 more years
later significant further advancements
continued in technology and medical
understanding and again the average life
expectancy of the species increased this
time to 273 years old on average again
however their frame of reference their
expectations of how long life lasted
rose right alongside although far less
often individuals of this time period
still experienced uncurable conditions
and diseases which shortened their
lifespans now however it would more
typically only be as low as 70 or 80
years old but of course the phenomenon
still occurred when individuals received
the news that they would likely only
live until their 70s or 80s suddenly
life became incredibly short they began
living and thinking and acting
differently often making major changes
in their life this continued on and on
into the future
every time the species added more time
to their life their expectations of how
long life should be neutralized their
perception of it being any longer no
matter what number the life expectancy
was it was always to be expected and
what was to be expected it didn't feel
long nor short no matter how it felt
though of course it was always short
whether it was one year or a thousand
both were fractions of fractions of a
microscopic blip of eternity and it was
only those who realized that the true
measurement of life was not the length
but the depth that ever really changed
how it felt
[Music]
you